everyone is warned and it's time to vote
on which theories you thought was the
best here's a recap of all of the
theories that one be sure to vote on
which one you thought was your favorite
at the end we're onto the final theory
number five theory number five comes
from Alfred Norwin barbacena and he has
a theory about the name war easter-egg
and Avengers in game an Avengers endgame
Ikoyi mentions an underground earthquake
off the coast of Africa many people
believe that this is an Easter Egg to
name war and that named war is going to
be the villain in Black Panther - Alfred
believes this and believes there will be
a war between Wakanda and Atlantis but
Alfred thinks that they have something
in common that they're both super
technologically advanced more than any
other civilizations in the world Alfred
thinks that some vibranium maybe came
from outer space and landed in the ocean
which is where Atlanteans get all of
their technology from just like
wakandans so in black panther 2 we'll
see the Battle of the two nations the
two most technologically advanced
civilizations on the planet and we will
see Namor versus Black Panther
I like this theory because I too believe
that the underground earthquake was
referencing Namor in Avengers endgame
he's been teased coming into the MCU for
a very long time now by Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige and it makes sense
if a meteor came from space landing in
Wakanda giving them their vibranium then
maybe another meteor landed in the ocean
giving Atlanteans vibranium this would
definitely make for an interesting
battle a battle between the two most
advanced cities on the planet this is
something that actually happens in the
comics Wakanda and Atlantis are at
constant war with one another so this
theory could definitely happen well
that's it for this week's theories let's
do a quick recap number two comes from
Ghaith of Anor and i'm really sorry if i
butchered your name there but gates
theory is that professor hulk actually
sees natasha after snapping just like
Thanos saw Gamora right after he snapped
in Avengers infinity war face says that
when Professor Hulk's eyes rolled back
and he passes out holding caps hand you
can clearly see his
mouth moving as if he's talking to
somebody maybe he's talking to Natasha
and holding her hand this actually makes
sense in a couple of different ways
because they a nose did see Kimura after
he snapped the Moro was the person that
Thanos cared about the most and Natasha
was probably the person that Bruce
Banner cared about the best and Gamora
was the soul sacrificed to obtain the
soul stone just like Natasha was the
soul sacrifice to obtain the soul stone
as well and if Thanos saw Gamora
after he snapped why wouldn't Bruce see
Natasha after he snapped it makes sense
so that's theory number two on tuck
theory number three theory number two
comes from youtube user Mysterio one two
six four and they have a theory on
Mysterio this theory states that the
ancient one actually taught Quinton Bank
in a very special way of the mystical
arts a way that only a few students that
trained under the ancient one knew of I
think that BEC took the power out of
hand killed the others that knew of the
power and left kamar Tosh this is why
Bex powers look very similar to dr.
Strange's but are still very different I
think that BEC used this power to travel
to a different earth to become their
hero figure like Iron Man but soon the
people of that new earth found out who
he really was a villain so when the snap
happened he took advantage of it crossed
over to our earth again after hearing
about the death of the ancient one and
claimed that the snap tore a hole in his
dimension I think that at about
three-quarters into the movie Doctor
Strange will tell Peter Beck's true
origin as Beck's betrayal being told
through the generations of the
Sorcerer's and will help Peter to
feedback with the help of shield and
then I think the end credits will be the
MCU setting up Kang the Conqueror as the
next villain the theory that Mysterio
was actually taught by the ancient one
is a good theory that has been going
around and their powers do look very
similar however the twist on this theory
is that Quinton Beck was actually taught
some ancient power that not a lot of
people were taught and then he killed
everybody else that knew it besides the
ancient one and then he used that power
to go to a different universe so this
theory is that the snap tearing a hole
through Earth's dimension is fake but
the multiverse is still real which I do
like the idea of and if this is the case
then dr. strange would definitely know
who Quinton Beck is so what would make
sense that he would tell spider-man
about his origin and help him defeat him
so that does it for theory number two on
theory number four comes from Alfredo
Moscoso and Alfredo's theory states that
there
be a major villain teased in phase four
like they did for Thanos but instead
what will be teased is the multiverse on
a collision course the build-up to this
will introduce the Fantastic Four x-men
and maybe characters like spider-man
2099 spider-gwen she-hulk her any
offshoot characters once they start
getting into the later phases the true
villain could be introduced which I
think would be Doctor Doom and while the
heroes try and stop the multiverse
collision dr. doom steals the powers of
the beyonders and creates the battle
world and the collision of the
multiverse happens and in that movie
everyone really dies except a handful of
heroes then in battle world we will see
famous again and maybe even see the
Phoenix force in Wolverine or Cyclops
and then in the last movie we will see a
team-up of the super heroes and the
super villains to go against the godlike
Doctor Doom with all of the beyonders
powers this would certainly be
absolutely insane to see happen but I
think everybody would love it and I
think once we heard multiverse a lot of
people started to fake battle world and
if you want an insanely huge event
something that Marvel has to do to
outperform Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in game battle world is
definitely something that could do that
and then the heroes and the villains
teaming up to go fight Doctor Doom
that's something that people have been
waiting for to see on screen for a super
long time now and now that the Disney
Fox deal is done and the multiverse has
been introduced hey we could see it
happen one day so that's it for a theory
number four on to the last and final
theory number five
[Music]
[Music]